biron New York is to political
correspondent the Washington Examiner
Jonathan trill he's a law professor at
George Washington University and they
both join us tonight professor truly
first to you why not just say we want to
impeach the president we think we think
he's committed high crimes and
misdemeanors here they do think that why
should that be embarrassing it's a
constitutional procedure well they
certainly should be open about if that
is their motivation and there's no
question that the preferred route for
the Constitution is to have a trial in
the Senate after impeachment in the
house they to have that decision you can
always still impeach someone once they
are removed from office there is an
ongoing academic debate whether in a
sitting president can be indicted but
most prosecutors yield to the
impeachment process I mean there's no
debate over what's the most democratic
mechanism for dealing with the president
who's done something wrong it's by using
the representatives that voters elected
correct right that's the preferred way I
mean the fact is that the framers gave
us a process by which we could first
impeach and then remove a president
right and you as long as you can prove
high crimes and misdemeanors clearly
some Democratic members are running on
that I don't see the problem frankly
with Trump also running on that guy I
think that for Trump to say look this is
about my impeachment I have no problem
with that because obviously that is an
underlying narrative for the other side
i but I think what will have to happen
first is Muller will have to issue a
report and then if Congress changes
hands particularly the house you could
very well see an impeachment process so
Byron the question of the subpoena
we saw yet another piece of information
leaked in the press recently that the
Muller people are considering
subpoenaing the president the White
House is saying on background we may
reject that where does it stand that's
where it stands right now we don't know
if Muller was really going to do this we
have never had this come to a conflict
in history the the Nixon case was about
subpoenaing documents about evidence not
actually testimony with Bill Clinton Ken
Starr subpoenaed Bill Clinton and then
they worked something out so that Ken
Starr would withdraw the subpoena while
Bill Clinton testified but he did get a
few things that you would not get
if you went in front of a grand jury he
got to keep his lawyers in the room with
him he did it on video he didn't go to a
grand jury room and the time was limited
so on the other hand he actually did
testify I think what you're seeing right
now with this case is that Trump has
realized perhaps lately that this is
more of a political fight this is an
impeachment fight more than anything so
while his lawyers talk about whether a
president can or cannot be subpoenaed or
called to testify Rudy Giuliani who's
really more of a spokesman right now and
others are working to discredit the
Independent Counsel because or the
Special Counsel in this case because if
it does come to the house and by the way
the reason Democrats aren't doing this
now is because they're a minority in the
House of Representatives sure but if
they're also not talking about it most
of them I mean some friends well members
remember the 2006 example when george w
bush's numbers were just terrible the
iraq war was going terribly the
democrats were running to try to win
congress in those midterms in oh six a
lot of democrats were talking about
impeachment but the public really didn't
want it Nancy Pelosi came out about this
time of the year in 2006 and said
impeachment is off the table today
though 71 percent of Democrats in a
recent poll said they want to see Trump
impeached if Democrats take that so that
full well what the leaders know that of
course and that's why it's so
disingenuous for them to deny it where
if you were running the president's
legal team in you should be I would say
would you allow him to speak to anyone
from Robert Moeller's investigation you
know look that's a tough question but I
actually think that he should have taken
the deal to go sometime ago and sit down
I wrote a column months ago that said
it's a good deal if they stick with the
four categories that Dowd and and anti
Cobb negotiated could you prepare the
president for that I think you could and
I think that was the quickest way to
defuse this the question is really the
endgame if you say if you basically defy
the the subpoena I think that he will
lose the existing case law favors
Moeller and once he wins in
process you give him a court order where
you can negotiate with him but he's in a
much stronger position he could demand
and a court could very well go along
with the conventional grand jury
appearance so the question is what is
the endgame that you're trying to lay
out
I personally believe the president could
sit suicide people keep on saying he's
gonna be a disaster he's gonna burst
into flames I disagree with that I've
done a lot of depositions that were more
complicated than this and I think you
could prepare this president for this
boy and Trump has done a lot of
deposition so his experience on the side
interviewed many times in seeing very
precise people go to jail true having
fallen into perjury traps by experts
look there's a risk some folks rights
here there's no question about it so
there's there's no no risk option yeah
gentlemen thank you both very much great
to see you